from your perspective can you summarize
the
important events around this amazing
saga they've been living through of
wall street bets the subreddit and
gamestop and
in general just what are your thoughts
about it from technical to the
philosophical level
i think it's amazing it's like my
favorite story ever
like when i was reading about it i was
like this is the best
um and it's it's also you know connected
with my company which we can talk about
but
what i liked about it is like i like
decentralized coordination
and looking at the mechanisms that these
are wall street bets
users use to hype each other up
to get excited to prove that that they
bought the stock and they're holding
um and and then also to see that
how big of an impact that that
decentralized coordination had
um it really was a big deal well you're
impressed by the distributed
uh coordination the collaboration
amongst like
i don't know what the numbers are i know
numerous looking at the data
after all this is over and done it'd be
interesting to see
like from uh a large-scale distributed
system perspective
to see how everything played out but
just from your current perspective
what we know is it obvious to you that
such
incredible level of coordination could
happen
where a lot of people come together in
distributed sense there's an emergent
behavior that happens after that
no it's not at all um obvious and one of
the reasons is the
lack of kind of like credibility to
coordinate with someone you need to kind
of make credible contracts or
credible claims so if you have um
a username on uh our wall street bets
like some of them are like deep [ __ ]
value is one of them that's an actual
username by the way we're talking about
there's a website called reddit and
there's subreddits on it
and a lot of people mostly anonymous i
i think for the most part anonymous can
create user accounts and then can then
just
talk on form like style boards you
should know what reddit is if you don't
know what reddit is check it out
uh if you don't know what red is maybe
go to uh
the uh ah sub subreddit first aww
with cute pictures of cats and dogs
that's my recommendation anyway
okay yeah that would be a good start to
reddit when you when you get into it
more go to our wall street bets
it gets dark quickly oh we'll probably
talk about that too
uh so you so yeah so there's these users
and it's there's no contracts like
you're saying there's no contracts the
the users are anonymous
but there are little things that that do
help so for example
if you've posted a really good
investment idea in the past
that exists on reddit as well and it
might have lots of upvotes
um and that's also kind of like giving
credibility to your
next to your next thing um and then they
are also
putting up screenshots uh like this this
is the
these i i here's the trades i've made
and here's a screenshot now you could
fake the screenshot
but um but but still it seems like if
you've got a lot of karma
and you've had a good performance on the
in the community
it somehow becomes credible enough for
other people to be like you know what
he actually probably did put a million
dollars into this
and you know what i can i can follow
that trade easily
and there's a bunch of people like that
so you're kind of uh integrating all
that information together yourself
to see like huh there's something
happening here and then you jump
onto this little boat of like behavior
like we should buy the stock or sell the
stock and then
another person jumps on another person
jumps on
and uh all of a sudden you have just a
huge number of people behaving in the
same direction it's like flock of
whatever birds exactly
what was strange with this one it wasn't
just let's all buy tesla
we love elon we love to tesla let's
let's all buy tesla
because that we've heard before right
everybody likes
um tesla now they do
um so what they did with this in this
case
they're buying a stock that was bad
they're buying it because it was bad
and that's really weird because that's a
little bit um
two galaxy brain for for a decentralized
community
um how did they come up with it how did
they know that was the right one
and the reason they liked it is because
it had really really high
short interest it had been shorted uh
more than its own
uh float i believe um and so they
figured out that if they all bought this
bad stock
they could short squeeze some hedge
funds
and those hedge funds would have to
capitulate and buy the stock at really
really high
prices and we should say that shorted
means that
these are a bunch of people when you
short a stock you're betting
on the on the you're predicting the
stock's going to go down and then you
will make money if it does
and then what's the short squeeze it's
really that
if you if you are a hedge fund and you
take a big short position
in a in a company um there's a certain
level at which
you can't sustain holding that position
there's no limit to how high a stock can
go but there is limit to how low
it can go right so if you short
something you have infinite loss
potential
and if the stock doubles overnight like
gamestop did
you're putting a lot of stress on that
hedge fund
and that hedge fund manager might have
to say you know what i have to get out
of the trade
and the only way to get out is to buy
the bad stock that they don't want like
they believe will go down
so it's an interesting situation
particularly because
it's not zero sum if you say let's make
let's all get together and make a bubble
in watermelons you buy a bunch of
watermelons the price goes up
it comes down again it's it's a
it's a zero-sum game if someone's
already shorter to stock and you can
make them short squeeze
it's actually a positive sum game so yes
some redditors will make
a lot of money some will lose a lot but
actually the whole group will make money
and that's really uh that's really why
it's
it was such a clever thing for them to
to do and coupled with the fact that
shorting i mean maybe you can push back
but
to me always from an outsider's
perspective seemed
i hope i'm not using too strong of a
ward but it seemed almost unethical
maybe not unethical maybe it's just the
[ __ ] thing to do
it's okay i'm speaking not from an
economics or financial perspective i'm
speaking from
just somebody who loves i'm a fan of a
lot of people i love celebrating the
success of a lot of people
and this is like the stock market
equivalent of like
haters i know that's not what it is i
know that there's efficient
you you want to have an economy
efficient mechanism for punishing
uh sort of over-hyped overvalued things
that's what shorthand guess is designed
for but just always felt like these
people
are just because they're not just
betting on the loss of the
company it feels like they're also using
their leverage and power
to manipulate media or just to write
articles
or just to hate on you on social media
and you get
to see that with the almost on so
so this is like the man the
people like hedge funds that we're
shorting are like the the
sort of embodiment of the evil
or just the bad guy the overpowerful
that's misusing their power
and here's the crowd the people that are
standing up and rising up so
it's not just that they were able to
collaborate
on wall street bets to sort of
effectively make money for themselves
it's also that this is like a symbol of
the people getting together
and fighting the centralized elites the
powerful
and that you know i don't know what your
thoughts are about that in general
at this stage it feels like that's
really exciting that
people have power just like regular
people have power
at the same time it's scary a little bit
because
you know just studying history people
could be manipulated by charismatic
leaders
and so like uh just like elon right now
is like manipulating
uh encouraging people to buy dogecoin or
whatever uh
the the like there can be good
charismatic leaders and there could be
bad charismatic legions
and so it's nerve wracking it's a little
bit scary how much power
subreddit can have to uh destroy
somebody
because right now we're celebrating they
might be attacking or destroying
somebody that
everybody doesn't like but what if they
attack somebody
that is actually good for this world so
that and that's
kind of the the awesomeness
and the price of freedom is like
it could destroy the world or it can
save the world but at this stage it
feels like i don't know
overall when you sit back do you think
this was just a positive
wave of emergent behavior is it because
there's something negative about what
happened
well yeah the the cool thing is the they
weren't doing anything
the the reddit people weren't doing
anything um exotic
it was an it was a creative trade but it
wasn't exotic
it wasn't it was just buying the stock
okay maybe they bought some
options too but um it was the hedge fund
that was doing the exotic
thing um so i like that it was it's hard
to say well
you know we've got together and we've
put all pooled all our money together
and now there's a company out there
that's worth more
what's wrong with that yeah right but it
doesn't talk about
you know the motivations which is and
then we destroyed some hedge funds in
the process
is there something to be said about the
the humor
and the i don't know the edginess
sometimes viciousness of that subreddit
i haven't looked at it
too much but it feels like people can be
quite
aggressive on there uh so is there
what is that is that what is that what
uh freedom looks like
i think it does yeah you definitely need
to let people
the one of the things that people have
compared it to is the occupy wall street
right which is let's say you know some
very sincere
uh liberals like 23 years old
whatever and they go out with signs and
they they have some kind of case to make
um but this isn't sincere uh
really um it's like um a little bit more
nihilistic
a little bit more yolo um and therefore
a little bit more scary
because who's scared of the who's scared
of the wall street occupy wall street
people with the signs
nobody but these hedge funds really are
scared i was scared
of the of the wall street bats people
i'm still scared of them
yeah the anonymity is a bit terrifying
and exciting
yeah i mean yeah i i don't know what to
do with it you know i've been
following events in russia for example
it's like there's a struggle between
centralized power and the distributed
i mean that's the struggle of uh the
history of human civilization right
but this on the internet just that
you can multiply uh people like
some of them don't have to be real like
you can probably create bots
like it starts getting me
me as a programmer i start to think like
me is one person
how much chaos can can i create by
writing some bots
yeah and i'm sure i'm not the only one
thinking that
uh there's i'm sure there's hundreds
thousands of good developers
out there listening to this thinking the
same thing and then
as that develops further and further in
the next decade or two
what impact does that have on financial
markets on just
destruction of reputations
of just or politics you know the the
bickering of
left and right political discourse the
dynamics of that
being manipulated by you know the people
talk about like russian bots
or whatever i we're probably in the very
early stage of that right
exactly and uh this is a good example
so do you have a do you have a sense
that most of wall street bets
folks are actually individual people
right that that's the feeling i have is
there's just individual
maybe young investors just doing a
little bit of an investment but just on
a large scale
yeah exactly the reason i found out what
i've known about
wall street for a while but the reason i
found about gamestop was this
just i met somebody at a party who told
me about it and he was like 21 years old
and he's like it's going to go up 100
in the next one day that we're talking
about in last year
uh this was probably no this was yeah a
few days ago oh
yeah it was like maybe um maybe two
weeks ago or something
um so it was it was already high game
stuff
um but it was just strange to me that
there was someone telling me at a party
uh how to trade stocks who was like 21
years old
um and uh and i started
yeah i started to look into it and um
yeah he and he did make he made yeah i
made 140
in one day uh he was right and now he's
um
you know supercharged he's a little bit
wealthier and now he's gonna look wait
for the next thing
and this decentralized entity is just
gonna get bigger and bigger
and they're gonna together search for
the next thing so there's thousands of
folks like him
and they're going to probably search for
the next thing to attack people that
have power in this
world that sit there with power right
now in government
and in finance in any kind of position
are probably a little bit scared right
now and honestly that's
probably a little bit good it's
dangerous but it's good
yeah it certainly makes you think twice
about shorting
it certainly it makes you think it's
right about putting a lot of money into
a short
like these funds put a lot into one one
or two names
and so it was very very badly risk
managed
you